nuevo incidente de violencia armada en
eeuu un sospechoso de 21 años fue
detenido en el suroeste del estado de
georgia unas horas después de
registrarse varios tiroteos en atlanta
el sospechoso fue identificado como
robert around long de 21 años quien vive
en el condado de cherokee pero
actualmente está bajo custodia en el
comando de clips y nos hemos estado
comunicando con él lo pusieron bajo
custodia por lo que sin incidentes los
ataques comenzaron alrededor de las
cinco de la tarde en un primer spa del
condado de cherokee donde cuatro
personas fallecieron y siguieron en
otros dos salones cercanos dejando otras
cuatro víctimas seis de ellas son de
ascendencia asiática lo que alimenta la
teoría de crímenes raciales no se
descarta nada estamos llevando a cabo
una investigación de homicidio múltiple
así que donde nos lleven las pruebas ahí
es donde irán los investigadores los
motivos del ataque múltiple aún son
desconocidos sin embargo los asesinatos
se produjeron
de una reciente ola de ataques contra
estadounidenses de origen asiático que
coincidió con la propagación del
coronavirus en el país